LANDFALL IN SOUTHWESTERN
LOUISIANA, IT’S A CATEGORY TWO
STORM -- WE ARE TRACKING IT AND
WILL HAVE AN UPDATE ON THAT AS
WELL.
GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT, FOR A
GUY WHO’S BEEN IN POLITICS ALL
OF HIS LIFE, JOE BIDEN NEVER
LEARNED TO LIVE VERY WELL.
YOU THINK HE WOULD’VE PICKED UP
SOME FLAIR OVER THE YEARS GIVEN
THE PRACTICE HE’S HAD, BUT NO.
IF HE STILL TELLS WHOPPERS LIKE
A CHILD LIKE THAT INSECURE FAT
KID IN HIS SIXTH-GRADE CLASS WHO
WAS ALWAYS BRAGGING ABOUT HOW
HIS DAD WAS A SECRET AGENT WHEN
ACTUALLY HE WORKED IN INSURANCE.
THERE WAS A SCARY GANG GUY
CALLED CORN POP, THEN I WENT TO
SOUTH AFRICA TO FREE
NELSON MANDELA FROM JAIL BUT A
BUNCH OF ARRESTED ME AT THE
AIRPORT BUT I FOUGHT THEM OFF --
OKAY, YOU SAY TO YOURSELF.
YOU’RE EMBARRASSED FOR THE GUY,
IT’S SO TRANSPARENT AND DUMB.
BUT BIDEN ISN’T EMBARRASSED, HE
ASSUMES YOU BELIEVE HIM, MAYBE
HE’S SO DEEP IN HIS INTERNAL
FANTASY WORLD HE DOESN’T CARE
WHAT YOU THINK.
EITHER WAY, HE KEEPS GOING, TALL
TALE AFTER A TALL TALE -- THEN I
WENT TO SEGREGATED BLACK
COLLEGE, THE GUYS THERE LOVED
ME.
THE WHOLE THING IS WEIRD, IT’S A
LITTLE SAD.
WHAT’S INTERESTING ARE THOSE
MOMENTS IN WHICH JOE BIDEN
DOESN’T LIE, HE DECIDES TO TELL
THE TRUTH IN THE FACE OF
CRITICISM.
THAT’S NOT AN EASY THING TO DO
FOR A MAN WHO’S DESPERATE TO BE
LOVED, YOU HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF
WHY IS HE DOING IT?
IT’S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW -- IT’S
INTERESTING.
REPEATEDLY HE’S BEEN ASKED IN
RECENT WEEKS WHETHER HE PLANS TO
PACK THE SUPREME COURT WITH
PARTISAN DEMOCRATS IF HE’S
ELECTED.
THE ANSWER IS OBVIOUS OF COURSE
I WOULD NEVER DO THAT, I’M NOT A
RADICAL, I MODERATE, I’M FROM
SCRANTON -- YOU CAN TRUST ME.
THAT’S ESSENTIALLY THE ANSWER HE
IS GIVEN ON A BUNCH OF DIFFERENT
ISSUES LIKE THE FRACKING BAN OR
THE GREEN NEW DEAL.
HE USED TO SUPPORT THOSE THINGS,
NOW HE CLAIMS HE DOESN’T SUPPORT
THEM.
HE WANTS TO WIN, HE’LL SAY
ANYTHING..
WHAT’S WEIRD IS THAT BIDEN ISN’T
TRYING TO REASSURE YOU THAT HE
WON’T PACK THE SUPREME COURT.
MOST AMERICANS DON’T WANT HIM TO
DO THAT, THEY DON’T WANT TO
DESTROY AN ENTIRE BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT.
AGAIN, BIDEN IS REFUSING TO
REASSURE THEM.
PACKING THE SUPREME COURT IS THE
ONE THING JOE BIDEN IS CERTAIN
TO DO IF HE SELECTED.
LISTEN TO HIS ANSWER FROM THE
QUESTION FROM YESTERDAY, HE
DOESN’T EVEN BOTHER WITH THE
COLORFUL STORY, HERE IT IS.
>> YOU’LL KNOW MY OPINION ON
COURT PACKING IF THE ELECTION IS
OVER.
IT’S A GREAT QUESTION AND I
DON’T BLAME YOU FOR ASKING BUT
YOU KNOW THE MOMENT I ANSWER
THAT QUESTION, THE HEADLINE AND
EVERY ONE OF YOUR PAPERS WILL BE
ABOUT THAT.
>> Tucker: WE SHOWED THAT CLIP
TO YOU LAST NIGHT, WE SHOWED IT
TO YOU AGAIN BECAUSE WE WANTED
TO MAKE SURE IT WAS REAL AND YOU
WANT IMAGINING IT, IT’S THAT
STRANGE.
HIS OFFICIAL ARTICULATED PLANNED
OUT SCRIPTED POSITION IS THAT
VOTERS ARE NOT ENTITLED TO KNOW
WHAT HE WILL DO TO THEIR
GOVERNMENT IF THEY ELECT HIM.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, IT’S
ITSELF A CLEAR ANSWER TO THE
QUESTION -- IT’S NOT LIKE HE’S
EVER THOUGHT ABOUT THE SUBJECT
OF PACKING THE COURT.
HE SAT ON THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE FOR DECADES FAMOUSLY
AND AT ONE POINT THE SPECIFIC
ISSUE CAME UP DURING A HEARING.
HERE’S WHAT BIDEN SAID ABOUT IT.
>> PRESIDENT ROOSEVELT CLEARLY
HAD THE RIGHT TO SEND TO THE
UNITED STATES SENATE A PROPOSAL
TO PACK THE COURT.
IT WAS TOTALLY WITHIN HIS RIGHT
TO DO THAT.
HE VIOLATED NO LAW, HE WAS
LEGALISTIC LEE ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT, BUT IT WAS A BONEHEAD
IDEA.
IT WAS A TERRIBLE MISTAKE TO
MAKE AND IT PUT IN QUESTION FOR
AN ENTIRE DECADE THE
INDEPENDENCE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT BODY INCLUDING
CONGRESS IN MY VIEW, THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT BODY IN THIS
COUNTRY, THE SUPREME COURT OF
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
>> Tucker: IT WAS LEGALISTIC
LEE CORRECT, EVEN THEN HE WAS
INARTICULATE.
HE DID SAY CLEARLY COURT PACKING
IS A TERRIBLE MISTAKE, IT WOULD
RUIN THE INTEGRITY OF THE
JUDICIAL BRANCH.
THAT’S NOT A PROFOUND INSIGHT,
IN FACT IT’S THE CONSENSUS VIEW
OF HISTORIANS AND JUDGES AND HAS
BEEN FOR DECADES.
ONCE AGAIN, POLLS SHOW AMERICANS
AGREE, THEY OPPOSE COURT
PACKING -- IT’S NOT A PARTISAN
ISSUE, IT’S COMMON SENSE.
THE SYSTEM HAS WORKED THIS WAY
FOR HUNDREDS OF YEARS -- LET’S
NOT WRECK IT NOW.
RUTH BADER GINSBURG HAD THE SAME
VIEW AND SHE SAID SO JUST LAST
YEAR.
>> I HAVE HEARD THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE ON THE DEMOCRATIC SIDE
WHO WOULD LIKE TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF JUDGES.
I THINK THAT WAS A BAD IDEA WHEN
PRESIDENT FRANKLIN DELANO
ROOSEVELT TRIED TO PACK THE
COURT.
IF ANYTHING, IT WOULD MAKE THE
COURT APPEAR PARTISAN.
WHEN WE ARE IN POWER, WE ARE
GOING TO THE NUMBER.
>> Tucker: SO THAT’S ONE OF
RUTH BADER GINSBURG’S FINAL
WISHES THAT WE ARE IGNORING,
APPARENTLY.
IT’S PRETTY INCONVENIENT
NEVERTHELESS, HOW IS THE BIDEN
CAMPAIGN EXPLAIN THIS AWAY?
THEY PUT SOME THOUGHT INTO THE
QUESTION -- JUST BEFORE THE LAST
DEBATE, THE BIDEN CAMPAIGN GOT
AN INTERN TO GOOGLE UP SOME
FACTS TO JUSTIFY COURT PACKING.
THEY CAME UP WITH
ABRAHAM LINCOLN A FEW MINUTES
BEFORE KAMALA HARRIS WENT ON
STAGE AND SHE REPEATED IT.
>> ABRAHAM LINCOLN WAS UP FOR
REELECTION AND IT WAS 27 DAYS
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
A SEAT BECAME OPEN ON THE
UNITED STATES SUPREME COURT.
ABRAHAM LINCOLN’S PARTY WAS IN
CHARGE NOT ONLY OF THE
WHITE HOUSE BUT OF THE SENATE.
BUT HONEST ABE SAID IT’S NOT THE
RIGHT THING TO DO.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE DESERVE TO
MAKE THE DECISION ABOUT WHO WILL
BE THE NEXT PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THAT PERSON
CAN SELECT WHO WILL SERVE FOR A
LIFETIME ON THE HIGHEST COURT OF
OUR LAND.
>> Tucker: THAT’S, LET HARRIS
HIS VERSION OF AMERICAN
HISTORY -- IT’S NOT CORRECT, NOT
SURPRISINGLY.
HARRIS DIDN’T GROW UP IN THIS
COUNTRY, SHE MOVED TO QUEBEC
WHEN SHE WAS 12 AND SHE DIDN’T
COME BACK UNTIL AFTER
HIGH SCHOOL.
IF THE QUESTION IS WHAT THE
CAPITAL OF CANADA, IT’S A PLACE
CALLED OTTAWA, KAMALA HARRIS
COULD PROBABLY TELL YOU.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO
ABRAHAM LINCOLN, SHE’S
COMPLETELY AT SEA, NONE OF WHAT
SHE SAID WAS TRUE.
MICHAEL BURLING GATEWOOD KNOW,
HE RUNS THE LINCOLN STUDIES
DEPARTMENT AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
ILLINOIS SPRINGFIELD AND HE WAS
BAFFLED ABOUT WHAT HE SAW.
I NEVER SEEN ANYTHING LIKE THAT
QUOTE AND ALL MY 36 YEARS OF
LINCOLN RESEARCH.
IN FACT HE DIDN’T IMMEDIATELY
NOMINATE A SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
BEFORE THE 1864 ELECTION BECAUSE
HE COULDN’T -- THE SCENT WAS NOT
IN SESSION AT THE TIME AND IN
1864, THERE WERE FEWER DIRECT
FLIGHTS TO WASHINGTON, SENATORS
COULDN’T HOP ON A REDEYE FROM
CALIFORNIA TO COME IN," THINGS
THINGS MOVED MORE SLOWLY.
IN DECEMBER, THE DAY AFTER THE
SENATE RECONVENED,
PRESIDENT LINCOLN IMMEDIATELY
NOMINATED A REPLACEMENT TO THE
COURT.
KAMALA HARRIS IS’S VERSION ISN’T
REAL.
IT’S HARD TO BELIEVE BUT THIS IS
REAL, THEIR PLAN TO COMPLETELY
CHANGE OUR AMERICAN FORM OF